Sich einmal fühlen
wie ein Astronaut im Weltall!
Im „Zero Gravity-Club“ wird dieser Traum für
50 prominente Gäste wahr
– bei einer Party an Bord eines Flugzeugs.
Flughafen Frankfurt am Main.
Musiker, Social-Media-Stars,
Künstler und Sportler aus aller Welt
checken ein
für das Abenteuer Schwerelosigkeit.
Darunter DJ Swanky Tunes aus Russland,
DJ Soda aus Südkorea,
der französische Fußballprofi
Sébastien Haller
und der deutsche Fernsehkoch Tim Mälzer.
Einverständniserklärung für
Körperverletzung?
Für das Feiern im Schwebezustand haben sie
sich besondere Aktionen vorgenommen.
Tim Mälzer möchte etwas zubereiten.
Es ist ein Experiment.
Es waren diverse Vorschläge.
Wir haben uns jetzt erst mal reduziert
auf ein einfaches Salatdressing.
Wir haben einige Ideen.
Ihr werdet schon sehen,
was wir vorbereitet haben.
Es wird etwas Einfaches sein,
das Spaß macht!
Auf geht's zum Airbus A310,
mit dem normalerweise Astronauten
für die Schwerelosigkeit trainieren.
Die Prominenten brauchen
zwar keinen Raumanzug,
aber eine gehörige Portion
Unerschrockenheit.
15 Parabelflüge werden sie erleben und dabei
jeweils 22 Sekunden lang schwerelos sein.
In 8.500 Metern Höhe wird es spannend.
Erst werden die Passagiere mit doppelter
Schwerkraft zu Boden gedrückt.
Dann heben sie plötzlich ab.
Kurz danach beginnt alles von vorn.
Das Flugzeug bewegt sich
dabei fast wie eine Achterbahn.
Für das Projekt haben sich die Veranstalter
mit erfahrenen Astronauten zusammengetan.
Das Mikrofon ist in Schwerelosigkeit,
während ich es von der einen Hand
zur anderen werfe.
Wenn ich hochspringe und meine Füße in der
Luft sind, dann schwebt es über meiner Hand.
Das machen wir auch mit dem Flugzeug.
Tim Mälzer hat nach kurzer Zeit den Dreh
raus und schüttelt sein Salatdressing.
Sébastien Haller schießt das erste Tor in
Schwerelosigkeit.
Die Organisatoren des Events haben sich auf
ausgefallene Party-Reihen spezialisiert.
Mit dem „Zero Gravity-Club“ sorgen sie für
Aufmerksamkeit.
Zum zweiten Mal feiern sie
die Party im Schwebezustand,
und der dauert insgesamt
rund sechs Minuten.
Zurück am Boden sind die Teilnehmer
des Flugs noch voller Adrenalin.
Ich hab' mich gefühlt wie Superwoman!
Und dann: Ich kann auch turnen!
Und mit anderen Leuten zusammenstoßen
und frei sein!
Hier sitzen erwachsene Leute,
die einfach sagen: Toll, toll, toll, toll, toll …
oh toll, toll, toll, toll, toll!
Es waren einige feuchte Augen dabei.
Um ehrlich zu sein:
Es ist einfach nur beeindruckend,
unbeschreiblich toll ... Ich bin sprachlos!
Das Gefühl der Schwerelosigkeit
hat alle schwer beeindruckt ...